as lawyers for the cartel allegedly are
you concerned about your life absolutely
not people always always ask that they
say you know whether it be cartel any
other crime organized crime street crime
whatever it is they say are you
concerned or nervous or scared and I say
no we're their last line that they're
we're their best friend if we're doing
our job right what if you're not I mean
didn't he get locked up he did he did I
don't think anyone was able to save him
from that look my boss did the trial and
he had the jury deliberating for seven
days which is a minor miracle given how
much evidence was against El Chapo seven
days they were deliberating right there
was mountains of evidence there was
operators to what I would deliberate to
write am I really gonna say it's a good
point it's a good point but look they
were they were sequestered I don't think
their life was in danger you know and
certainly as a defense lawyer you know I
don't people ask that question but I've
never felt that way in my life that I
was in bad you know faith or in danger
one of our clients